[Musique]
bonjour jimmy bonjour à toutes et à tous
notre invité ce matin et marie-josée
joseph louis bonjour
vous êtes professeur documentaliste et
référente culture au collège perrinon à
fort de france et vous êtes venu nous
parler d'une opération autour du créole
qui s'achève ce vendredi et qui s'est
déroulée dans le cadre général de la
semaine académique qui est consacré donc
au créole alors vous au collège perrinon
vous avez mis en place pour cette
semaine académique un programme
particulier de sensibilisation des
élèves non seulement à la langue créole
au langage créole mais aussi plus
largement à la culture martiniquaise
d'expression en créole et alors cela est
tout d'abord passer par la diffusion de
musique lors de l'accueil de la
communauté scolaire le matin 1 ça s'est
fait sur plusieurs jours alors comment
cet accueil en musique avec quelle
musique at il était perçu notamment par
les élèves oui donc voilà donc c'est
bien cela
la semaine académique cette année a eu
pour thème
le champ par dont la chanson populaire
créole et donc partant de ce thème nous
avons élaboré mon collègue et moi mon
collègue professeur de créole monsieur
jean alphonse marc-antoine nous avons
élaboré tout un programme qui parle de
ce thème pour pouvoir sensibiliser les
élèves à l'oralité puisque le créole
c'est quand même à l'origine c'était que
de l'oral et les changes était orale et
puis sensibiliser les élèves pour les
familiariser également avec la langue
créole cela d'autant plus qu'au collège
cela fait deux ans que nous avons
une option kréyol alors parfois tout le
monde ne le sait pas les parents ne le
savent pas mais ça fait deux ans que
l'option kréyol existent aux côtés d
autres d autres langues pas pour toutes
les classes pour les classes de 4e et 3e
alors nous ça commence dès là dès la
5eme dès la 5e a ensuite sur ce point si
en 4e et en 3e d'accord quelle musique
vous avez choisi alors de 16 ans non
mais quel genre de musique c'est quoi du
zou que de la musique traditionnelle je
sais pas moi de la biguine de la mazurka
vous avez mélangez le tout alors on a
essayé de faire un panel très large
histoire de de présenter aux élèves les
chansons traditionnelles
telles que
voit brûler de gênes moulin nous avons
également proposer un mix de belley qui
a été revisitée par monsieur
reine-adelaïde
maurice reine adelaïde voilà que je ça
lui que je remercie est grandement parce
que c'est je trouve ça magnifique et
puis et puis surtout on a démarré avec
le chant de ralliement qui a été retenu
au point qu'à des milk qui est
kréyol l'école voilà qui retrace un peu
comme on apprenait l'école à l'école
mais dans les couloirs mais chanté en
créole et chanté en créole
bon ben voilà alors autres autre
déclinaison
vous avez apporté de l'information sur
une application qui s'appelle giga
martinique alors à quoi elle sert cette
application pourquoi en avoir parlé aux
élèves et aux professeurs alors nous
sommes près de 500 élèves dans
l'établissement
l'option kréyol ces niveaux 5e 4e 3e il
y avait beaucoup de place pour tout le
monde c'est sûr et donc le créole
parfois on le parle on l'a appris à la
maison on l'a appris avec les copains
dans les couloirs et et puis vous avez
de nouveaux élèves qui arrivent dans
l'établissement à tout moment et qui
sont plongés dans notre univers que
notre société créolophones et donc
pouvoir permettra à tous
d'apprendre le créole on a trouvé que
c'était une très bonne chose donc c'est
une application itunes et
l'apprentissage c'est une application
jusqu'à mais nous y voilà qui permet
apprendre en toute autonomie et je salue
d'ailleurs
une collègue professeur madame
marie-josée desnel qui à l'initiative de
cette application qu'elle a réalisé en
partenariat avec un médecin allemand et
qui est professeur d'allemand et de
crayons le lycée acajou 2 et que
vraiment c'est grâce à elle qu'on on
peut je peux dire que les soutes à
chacun on peut apprendre le créole
l'écouté c'est un outil dont vous faites
usage au collège ah non du tout on l'a
utilisé essentiellement pour démarrer
l'activité et pourquoi pas peut-être
qu'on pourrait envisager
un travail pédagogique avec cet outil
pourquoi pas d'accord avec vous avez
présenté l'application on a présenté
l'application est vraiment donne la
liberté aux élèves comme aux adultes de
la télécharger et puis d'en faire un bon
usage alors il y a eu également au cours
de cette semaine donc qui donc a
commencé le 28 mars et qui s'achève ce
vendredi ça va être un peu le point
d'orgue on va dire le temps fort de la
semaine on y viendra mais il y a eu
également des échanges cette semaine au
collège perrineau entre les élèves
créolistes donc de 4e et 3e avec un mets
ta parole un conteur martiniquais allez
les gars exactement donc ça s'est passé
hier
nous avons nous avons reçu un cran mais
ta parole comme vous dites monsieur
alain les gars s ancien éducateur
spécialisé et
et qui est venu présenter aux élèves un
jeu qui existaient à l'époque au niveau
de l'habitation qui s'appelle le team
est bon c'était
les gens les gens se rassemblaient
autour des habitations pour votre chine
pour jouer aux dominos pour faire la
danse du bel air et donc il a proposé sa
aux élèves on était vraiment plonger
dans le monde de l'oralité kréyol donc
au départ c'était pour les élèves de 3e
et 4e créolistes mais après on s'est
retrouvé avec d'autres élèves un petit
peu intéressés et donc la porte était
ouverte à tous ceux qui le tous ceux qui
le souhaitaient et donc c'est un jeu qui
consiste à apposer des devinettes et
et de trouver les réponses et je dois
vous dire que même moi parfois j'ai j'ai
eu à me creuser un peu la tête pour
pouvoir trouver des réponses si je peux
si vous voulez je peux vous donner
quelques exemples un exemple le temps
par exemple
qui ça au cas où mais des fois adam
moment en fois adam mois et jamais un
temps en en
moi je donne ma langue au chat bon bah
ça
va nous répond selon vous voyez c'est la
lettre m deux fois dans un moment m une
fois dans le mois et jamais dans une
allée à huy la lettre m donc voilà donc
c'était des jeux de mots ce qui faisait
à l'époque et on a trouvé ça très très
très intéressante à la lega reste donc
compteur mais ta parole qui fait partie
de ceux qui vont donc participer
aujourd'hui je les dis à cette clôture
de cette semaine du créole au collège
perrineau alors il y aura le musicien
willy léger le flûtiste gérard féliciter
un autre musicien qui va faire du temps
beau et du petit bois reymond dantin
enfin voilà ils sont comme ça quelques
uns qui vont participer aux migrants
parole
alors expliquez nous ce que ce sera là
tout à l'heure ce matin au collège
perrineau un tableau théâtrale de rue
pour sensibiliser les élèves à un
certain nombre de thématiques de société
allant par exemple la violence ou la
femme dans notre société oui voilà donc
en fait
la société raphaël concept je pense
qu'ils vont pas tarder à arriver au
collège et ils vont nous plonger ils
vont plonger tous les spectateurs dans
un usine dans l'univers du conte créole
d'hier à aujourd'hui sur des thématiques
comme vous l'avez dit qu'ils ont été
choisis que nous avons choisi ensemble
avec
mon collègue et la vie scolaire qui nous
a accordé beaucoup dead sur sur ce
projet et qui touchent des thèmes qui
touchent un peu aux élèves le
harcèlement la violence le respect qu'il
est nécessaire d'avoir entre adultes
mais aussi entre jeunes qui à autre
chose au-delà de ça qui peut qui peuvent
rassembler
les élèves voilà alors voilà et ce sera
fait donc sous forme de théâtre de rue
c'est ça se soigne c'est une pièce de
théâtre c'est une pièce de théâtre qui
vraisemblablement qui va permettre
d'avoir un échange entre les artistes et
également un spectateur voilà donc avec
de l'interactivité aussi et donc voilà
spectacle théâtral de rue tableau
théâtrale de rue qui donc que ce sera
entre le conte créole d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui et occasion de
sensibiliser élèves un certain nombre de
thèmes importants allez pour terminer ce
théâtre de rue cette représentation
d'une scène d'une pièce de théâtre de
rue sera suivie évidemment d'une danse
belle est aussi alors présenté par une
élève il a valu la colère perino une
élève du collège péguy nos qui est
également créolistes puisqu'elle est en
skate en cinquième et
elle s'appelle beaunesne à elie dont la
mère est professeur de ballet et donc
forcément les immerger dans dans cet
univers il va nous proposer une petite
danse baylet en compagnie d'une heure d
une assistante d'éducation
mademoiselle matelot
ils seront accompagnés par les musiciens
de raphaël concept qui qui acceptent
volontiers de voix la voix l'allaitement
la musique qui va ponctuer et voilà qui
va ponctuer en beauté donc cette semaine
donc du créole au collège perrinon à à
fort de france donc avec un programme
particulier un programme tout au long
des 2 c de ces derniers jours programme
de sensibilisation des élèves à la
culture et à la langue créole merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos questions
et d'avoir expliquer tout cela à nos
auditrices et auditeurs marie-josée
joseph louis on le rappelle vous êtes
vous-même professeur documentaliste et
référente culture dans ce collège
perrinon de fort-de-france bonne journée
et bon week-end à toutes et à tous merci
au revoir